Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Cette photo a été prise le 1er mars 1975
à l’école maternelle de Qanono à Lifou,
le jour de la rentrée scolaire.
Je porte une petite robe mission, cette
robe traditionnelle de Nouvelle-Calédonie
qui est portée majoritairement
par les femmes kanak, ici et ailleurs.
Je ne le savais pas encore,
mais cette robe popinée,
orange avec ses motifs bleus,
sa dentelle fine et blanche,
ça sera le point de départ
de mon aventure d’entrepreneur
avec des femmes entrepreneurs.
Vous devez vous demander : « Mais pourquoi
elle ne dit pas ‘entrepreneuse’ ?
Pourquoi elle ne met pas ce terme
‘entrepreneur’ au féminin ? »
Vous voyez ?
Même moi, je trouve bizarre,
voire pas naturel,
d’utiliser le terme « entrepreneuse ».
Et pourquoi ?
Est-ce parce qu’on n’a pas l’habitude
de prendre cette parole ?
Parce qu’on n’a pas l’habitude
de voir des femmes chefs d’entreprise
se mettre en avant ?
Ou bien parce que dans notre société,
nous sommes trop peu nombreuses
à nous identifier comme telles ?
Et pourtant,
savez-vous que l’année dernière
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
selon les statistiques
d’une structure de micro-crédit,
47% des projets soutenus financièrement
sont portés par des femmes ?
Et parmi ces femmes entrepreneuses,
63% vivent en tribu.
Ces chiffres résument
partiellement notre challenge,
celui de passer
d’une économie dite informelle
vers un cadre visible, quantifiable,
un dispositif social solidaire
qui prendra en compte les spécificités
de calendrier, de rythme de production,
d’éloignement,
et qui nous fera peut-être une place
dans l’économie de marché.
Nous allons y arriver.
Et il faudra du temps pour cela.
Du temps parce que nous ne pouvons pas
faire table rase d’une éducation,
cette même éducation
qui nous a toujours cantonnées
dans un coin de l’espace sociétal.
Même si parfois, c’était arrangeant
d’exister dans ce statut.
Et même parfois pour se dédouaner,
on dit qu’il ne faut pas
confondre vitesse et précipitation.
Or, il est temps de bousculer notre
éducation pour faire avancer les femmes.
Parler d’émancipation économique
des femmes ce soir devant vous,
ce n’est pas une chose facile pour moi.
C’est même risqué parce
qu’on ne s’y attend peut-être pas.
Parce qu’on n’a pas l’habitude
de passer d’une case à une autre.
Ou peut-être parce qu’on a trop l’habitude
de voir des gens dans une case
que, parfois, ça surprend
de les voir sortir de leur case.
Je suis une femme issue
de la société civile
qui observe comme vous, qui constate,
que depuis les accords passés
entre l’État français
et les deux principaux partis
en Nouvelle-Calédonie,
donc depuis les accords de Matignon,
depuis l’accord de Nouméa,
nous les femmes,
et particulièrement les femmes kanak,
nous avons été oubliées
dans la conversation économique.
À chaque fois que
(Ton pontifiant)
des outils de développement
économique ont été mis en place
dans un cadre de rééquilibrage
pour des promoteurs
de projets d’origine kanak,
(Reprend sa voix normale)
ces dispositifs ont été pensés
par des hommes pour des hommes.
Et nous les femmes,
et nous les femmes kanak -
Tut tut tut tut -
(Ton pontifiant)
nous verrons cela après,
lorsque le moment sera venu.
(Soupire)
(Reprend sa voix normale)
L’histoire des Kanaks,
c’est toujours l’histoire des hommes.
Les femmes,
nous sommes toujours là,
simplement invisibilisées.
Il ne s’agit pas de répéter que
les femmes étaient aussi dans les combats,
il faut simplement le dire,
car cela n’a jamais été dit ou si peu.
J’ai compris depuis peu
que pour être écouté,
il faut être émancipé économiquement
et l’autonomisation financière des femmes
doit être un objectif collectif.
Pour nous les femmes kanak,
une solution simple,
c’est la collaboration,
c’est la co-construction,
c’est la coopération.
Pourquoi c’est simple pour nous ?
Parce que c’est déjà notre façon de vivre,
c’est déjà notre façon de faire,
dans notre clan, dans notre tribu.
Lorsque j’étais enfant à Luecila,
le dimanche après-midi,
mes frères jouaient au foot,
tandis que nous, les filles, on devait
rester à Eika, la maison commune,
avec une tante ou une grand-mère
pour apprendre à coudre,
à tisser et aussi à tricoter.
Les grandes sœurs, elles devaient
nous guider, nous les petites,
dans les techniques de tressage.
Vous savez, ces choses qui vont
servir plus tard à tenir son foyer
alors qu’on déroule un tapis
rouge aux petits garçons.
Mais heureusement que nous avons réussi
à valoriser cette transmission
entre les femmes !
C’est comme ça qu’on apprend, ensemble.
On apprend ainsi nos taperas,
les chants polyphoniques,
une manière ludique de transmettre
nos langues dans les îles.
De cette manière, on apprend
aussi à cuire notre pain marmite,
à confectionner notre robe mission
et pourquoi pas, à adapter
ensemble un nouveau schéma
avec des enjeux de maintenant.
On apprend par imitation.
Moi aussi, j’ai un modèle :
ma mère, qui a commencé à enseigner
dès l’âge de 19 ans en 1958.
Elle s’est émancipée
des injonctions de la société.
Elle a vécu son rêve :
devenir maîtresse d’école dans sa tribu,
tout en étant en même temps
mère de sept enfants.
Même si je reconnais la chance
d’être née dans une famille
où l’instruction est centrale,
prendre la parole, savoir l’utiliser,
demeure encore un palier
long et difficile à atteindre.
Mais alors, comment faire
de tous ces apprentissages -
l’artisanat, la maîtrise de la parole -
une force économique ?
Comment transformer
en statuts d’entreprise, en dispositif,
cette pratique sociale chère
aux femmes océaniennes,
avec nos méthodes d’acquisition du geste
artisanal qui ont fait leurs preuves ?
Comment créer de l’emploi
à partir de la transmission
des savoir-faire traditionnels ?
Monter un projet,
opérer une entreprise avec toutes ces
valeurs qui nous animent depuis toujours,
peut aussi nous épanouir
parce qu’on assume de vouloir faire
du business comme les blancs,
parce qu’on assume de parler d’argent
en dehors de la coutume,
parce qu’on assume de vendre
un service à sa propre famille -
oui ! -
parce que j’assume de dire que je suis
entrepreneuse dans l’espace public.
Alors comment j'ai procédé ?
J’ai d’abord demandé de l’aide
dans ma famille, dans mon clan.
J’ai questionné ces personnes sur ma
place, mon nouveau statut d’entrepreneuse.
J'ai bousculé l'échiquier familial
pour entreprendre.
J’ai tout largué pour vendre
des robes missions
et j’ai sauté dans le grand vide
pour aider d’autres femmes.
Et là, j’ai créé mon entreprise numérique.
E j’ai décidé de prendre la parole
et de soutenir d’autres femmes
à participer au débat public,
à proposer leur solution,
leur vision pour notre pays.
Fédérer une cinquantaine de couturières,
de tresseuses et d’autres artisanes,
de Nouvelle-Calédonie
et bientôt du Pacifique,
sur un outil collaboratif numérique,
ce n’est pas de l’innovation seulement,
c’est notre salut,
aujourd’hui et maintenant.
C'est la première pierre.
Cet outil numérique, c'est une case, une
grande case et chacune apporte sa brique.
Et la parole des femmes,
c’est le ciment.
Cet outil solidaire,
il a aussi d’autres avantages.
Il permet à des femmes éloignées
géographiquement de se rapprocher,
de faire pays, d’entreprendre ensemble
et d’être libres de choisir.
Je veux inspirer des femmes.
Et des hommes aussi.
Je ne suis pas toute seule
à vouloir le faire.
J’ai juste suivi des rôles modèles
avant nous.
Déwé Gorodey,
femme politique, écrivaine kanak.
Ou encore Wazana Naxue,
syndicaliste kanak,
traductrice de langue drehu.
Elles ont fait les barricades avant nous
et enfreint certaines règles pour nous.
Après ces deux grandes dames
et d’autres figures féminines,
de plus en plus de femmes
kanak pourront se dire :
« Moi aussi, j’ose me lever,
moi aussi, j’ose m’exprimer,
moi aussi, j’ose montrer mon visage.
Moi aussi, j’ose m’épanouir...
et pourquoi pas entreprendre ? »
Parler de développement
économique en tribu,
c’est introduire
des concepts venus par la mer,
comme l’innovation, la valeur
monétaire, le business plan,
dans un débat kanak,
océanien, traditionnel,
rythmé par nos événements
coutumiers et religieux
pour renforcer nos liens
tout en en créant de nouveaux.
Voilà, nous y sommes.
Pour entreprendre,
nous devons utiliser cette force.
Nous devons utiliser les relations
familiales exponentielles
des réseaux sociaux
pour notre marketing,
pour tester nos produits,
pour diffuser notre savoir-faire,
pour communiquer nos valeurs,
et surtout pour montrer
que nous sommes capables.
Il ne s’agit pas de placer le Kanak au
centre du dispositif du vivre ensemble,
comme on l’entend partout
dans les accords post-coloniaux,
les bavardages publics.
Désormais, c’est aussi la femme
qu’il faut placer au centre du dispositif
socio-économique calédonien.
Et je parle de toutes les femmes
de Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi se priver
de la moitié de la population
pour décider, agir, créer de la richesse
et surtout avancer ensemble ?
L’intérêt -
L’intérêt pour nous les femmes, c’est
de raconter nous-mêmes notre histoire,
nos échecs, nos victoires.
Avec nos émotions.
Car au-delà du symbole,
au-delà de l’héritage de l’Évangile
qui avait couvert la femme kanak
avec cette robe mission,
nous, nous disons que ce symbole,
c’est le prétexte pour l’émancipation.
Et c’est aussi au travers de nos exemples
que nous pourrons démontrer que nos
entreprises sont des initiatives durables
et que notre activité économique,
elle contribue aussi
à la cohésion du groupe tribal,
du groupe clanique insulaire.
En réalité, les femmes, depuis toujours,
elles font l’aménagement des territoires.
Lorsque je regarde ces deux photos,
je ne peux pas m’empêcher de penser
que si nous, les femmes,
à partir de maintenant,
si nous prenons notre place
dans tous les débats,
si nous aussi, nous nous engageons
pour réécrire les règles
pour que le prochain scénario
ne soit pas pire que les deux précédents,
nous rendrons un grand service
à la société calédonienne.
Nos enfants en seront bénéficiaires.
Et peut-être même que nos petits-enfants,
ils se rappelleront
la première poignée de mains
entre deux femmes calédoniennes
et, pourquoi pas, de la première
femme kanak sénatrice coutumière.
C’est pour ça que je m’adresse aux femmes,
à nous, les femmes dans ce pays :
le combat a changé.
De nouvelles barricades sont là
pour lutter contre l’invisibilisation
des femmes en Nouvelle-Calédonie.
Entreprendre, c'est une solution
que je propose.
Regardez : eux, ils sont debout.
Depuis longtemps.
Maintenant,
c’est notre tour.
Levez-vous, mesdames.
S’il vous plaît, levez-vous toutes.
Levez-vous, toutes les femmes.
(Applaudissements)
Reprenons-nous et prenons, nous aussi,
le pouvoir économique dans notre pays.
L’émancipation des femmes
est nécessaire.
est urgente.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)